a trip to an emergency room in
tegucigalpa honduras three years ago
changed anna lopez's life forever that's
when she learned for the first time that
she was pregnant
between 20 and 25 weeks along
i didn't visit the hospital because of a
pregnancy they were the ones who told me
i was pregnant
but they said my child had been dead for
two days i didn't even know what to feel
anna says her emotional and physical
trauma was suddenly made worse
after doctors listed her emergency as an
intentional termination of pregnancy
which in honduras is a crime punishable
by up to six years in prison
i had some markings on my stomach and
because of those markings they said it
was an abortion
when i was discharged from the hospital
the police were already waiting
gabriella a defense attorney with the
women's rights group somos muchas
says that more than 60 women or girls
have faced prosecution in honduras since
2012
under the country's strict anti-abortion
laws
in many cases criminalization is due to
obstetric emergencies
that medical reports list as abortions
despite often being inconclusive
these reports are then used as evidence
against women who can spend
three four or more years locked in a
judicial process
that is long and exhausting in january
of this year feminist activists hoped
honduras might follow the lead of
argentina where abortion was recently
legalized
up to 14 weeks into a pregnancy
but instead honduran lawmakers passed a
constitutional reform
making it nearly impossible to ever
legalize abortion in the future
human rights organizations have called
the legislation an assault on women's
reproductive rights
honduras is currently one of the only
few countries in in the continent in
latin america and the caribbean that
completely ban abortions without
any explicit uh exception right the
country also has one of the highest
rates of sexual violence in the world
uh with a woman reporting sexual
violence every three hours
the new constitutional amendment was
championed by honduras's ruling
conservative party
in what many see as an extreme political
move as the country nears national
elections
and where religion plays an oversized
role in political decision-making
around the world abortion rates are
higher in countries where abortions are
banned
according to a 2017 global study
in honduras it's estimated that between
50 and 80
000 women risk their lives every year by
resorting to clandestine abortion
clinics
at 24 years old anna lopez says having a
criminal record has kept her from
finding steady work
or returning to school anna's criminal
case remains open in the honduran court
system
if convicted she faces a sentence of
three to six years in prison
for the quote interruption of life after
the moment of conception
rapalo al jazeera